ich habe eben gehört ich sage da viel
zusammen aufgetreten in dieser sendung
und man frage sich aber mich überhaupt
noch ein laut und möchte deshalb habe
ich mir das vorgenommen die definitiven
wutbürger these dass plate war für den
wutbürger oder gleichsam selber zum
wutbürger zu werden um ein ärgernis sie
zu thematisieren
nämlich die
unglaublich teuren schädlichen leerläufe
der politik die in effizienz die uns das
leben vermisst nur ein paar beispiele
aus jüngster zeit
40.000 40.000 politiker beamte
wissenschaftler sind an die
klimakonferenz von glasgow gefahren mit
jedem privat jets mit ihrem das ist der
klimaschutz dann haben wir die
koalitionsverhandlungen in berlin da
habe ich gelesen
300 unterhändler in 22 arbeitsgruppen
haben sozusagen die vorstufe eines
koalitionsvertrags aus gehabt wir haben
was sind denn das für ineffiziente
leerläufe was machen diese politiker
eigentlich wenn sie mal wirklich ein
problem lösen müssen wenn sie schon 300
unterhändler brauchen und so häufig gibt
es viele gleichzeitig drängt sich die
politik immer tiefer die man in unser
leben hinein sie wollen uns schon sorgen
haben wir noch ins restaurant gehen
dürfen welche medizinischen behandlungen
wir müssen den staat um erlaubnis bitten
wenn wir unser haus verlassen wollen
deshalb fordere ich hier ich glaube als
erster mensch weltweit ich fordere hier
das menschenrecht von der politik in
ruhe gelassen zu werden ich glaube es
gibt ein grundrecht darauf von der
politik in ruhe gelassen zu werden vor
allem von dieser leerlauf politik die
uns das leben vermisst so jetzt haben
wir aber endlich einmal konsens in
dieser runde wurde es natürlich jetzt
bewusst überspitzt ich find's großartig
liebe es auch hier zu zuhören haben
natürlich als ich und einer these gehört
habe auch überlegt wie kannst du denn da
versuchen gegen zu argumentieren um das
mal aufbrechen
minütigen nachdenken klar geworden dass
es kaum möglich ist dann egal welchem
bereich man durch denkt ja egal welchem
bereich unseres lebens oder auch die
politischen es ist einfach enorm
aufgebläht alles und es ist ein
kernproblem das unabhängig von den
inhalten wie dieser struktur also dieses
vorherrschen des dieses dieses
aufgebläht und auch gleich sein am ende
bringt uns nicht weiter das gilt für
alle bereiche stichwort dem auch
bürokratie werde mir anschauen was mit
unseren unternehmen gemacht wie die
kommen ja gar nicht um dazu etwas zu
erwirtschaften oder sich um wirklich
wichtige sachen zu kümmern weil ich nur
damit beschäftigt sind abzuarbeiten nach
schiene brauchst du dieses noch als
jenes noch bestes beispiel auch bauen ja
ich meine warum haben wir denn die
probleme die wir haben den mangel den
wir haben es liegt ja jetzt nicht nur an
an spekulanten sondern vor allem auch
daran dass so viele bauvorschriften das
ist so teuer geworden ist dann sitzen
wir ja und wundern uns also absolut sehr
gute banken wickeln daum ohne gemeinsame
ob ein aktionsbündnis für das recht von
natürlich das einzige spitze und so
scharf aber ich find den grundgedanken
als im rosenhag aber ich bin roche und
wahrheit werden wir das total in ruhe
gelassen nämlich dadurch dass kaum muss
man sich das anders
jetzt muss der
nacht angegriffen an dieser these
vertrat ich mich gleich mit mit
professor
also ich finde das ist doch dass wir
sehr in ruhe gelassen werden weil
ziemlich wenig nach außen dringt aus
diesen arbeitsgruppen die arbeiten
ziemlich leise oder schlecht ich finde
es natürlich schlecht journalist aber
der russe hat ja mehr als privatbürger
hier geredet ja von den medien falsch
eingenommen wird von daher glaube ich
erstens werden wir dadurch sehr in ruhe
gelassen zweitens glaube ich wenn wir
darüber sprechen dass man doch in dieser
zeit alle irgendwie mitnehmen muss und
insgesamt und sowieso dass es nicht zur
spaltung kommt ja da braucht man
natürlich in all diesen parteien alle
unterschiedlichen flügel wo man
zumindest so tun kann man hätte sie
gefragt denn um wahrheit ist doch eh am
ende entscheiden ist eben nicht 300
unterhändlern 22 arbeitsgruppen sondern
eine sehr kleine form die saßen als
halle und haben wahnsinnig viel
aufgeschrieben und jetzt kommen olaf
scholz christian lindner annalena
baerbock und machen das unter sich sagt
ich mache mir einfach sorgen von dem was
frau bosbach vor sich ist auch passiert
wie gesagt sie wünschte sich eine etwas
sparsamer politik aber wenn sie schon
für die vorstufe eines
koalitionsvertrags 300 unter händlern
braucht wie viele brauchen sie darum das
grenzte borgel zwischen polen da
brauchen sie alle regionen da brauchen
sie millionen von unternehmen um ein
reales problem zu lösen ich sehe das
nicht unheimlich jetzt ehrlich 300
unterhändler in 29 und sein weil ich
weiß wie am ende am ende machen es ja
machen die es ja viel kleineren gruppe
und lass die doch schreiben was sie
wollen da kann man also
haben sie kräftig gefüllt wie sehen sie
das also erst mal ich glaube dass wir
attraktiv und politik miteinander
verwechselt haben ja sie haben nicht
mehr viel bürokratie gesprochen sie
haben mir von der politik gesprochen und
dass man
einander übergehen aber es hat was genau
das gleiche
und das nächste ist verhandlungen sind
natürlich immer extrem frustrierend von
außen betrachtet ist man ein bisschen
sehr viel interessen unter einen hut
gebracht werden und ehrlich gesagt ich
würde mich über 300 politiker erst mal
nicht so wahnsinnig viel sorgen machen
das ist wie so ein multi kern prozessor
her also stellen sie vor das wird
parallelisiert die ganze arbeit und auch
die art und weise wird das auf eine
vernünftige art und weise hoffentlich
vernünftige art und weise aufgeteilt und
diese aushandlungsprozess der ist
einfach extrem wichtig das ist mir doch
viel lieber als wir da drei leute
zusammensitzen aber sagen per ordre de
mufti bestimmten befinden jetzt darüber
was alles richtig ist für den rest der
welt und das wird durchgesetzt werden
zwischen drei und 3 100
das ist ja unser
geld mit
großem öffentlichen platz abstimmung
über mehr als 300 verstehen aber sie
bekommen keinen glauben sie bekommen
keinen
das
ist ziemlich in der engener kannst du
aus helfen ja deutlich gesagt sagen wenn
man will wer sich in einer runde wenig
rede soll ich meinen laden ihr wisst ja
ich bin fan und so fasziniert sorge
nichts mehr jetzt absolut positiv
gemeint ist du weißt ich muss sagen ich
finde er dass politiker mehr verdienen
sollten also dieses argument geht mir so
dermaßen auf den geist in der
bevölkerung immer warum die
bundestagsabgeordneten immer noch reden
müssen immer noch 1000 nebentätigkeit
machen wäre doch viel besser sie würden
mehr vom staat kriegen wenn prozentig
nur auf die
jetzt habe ich die letzten wochen hier
offensichtlich an eine betonwand herren
argument liegt da ist kein kein funken
vor kein closed beta der erkenntnis ist
die aktie knickte kann kein welt nicht
leisten weil wir gesagt nein
entschuldigung ist das gewiss mehr ganz
ernst die journalistin hat die aufgabe
diesen aus wucherungen der politik hier
etwas die in die stammelf leisten ja
schon kein 300 und rennt dafür liegen
seinen untauglichen vertrag
wird oder
ich sage es nichts mehr salz kommen bau
zwei leuten mit seinem weißen kittel
tragen
ich sage damit meinen namen
aber ich habe nicht das
weiß ein rhetorischer trick nein
zum abschluss vielleicht was was glaubst
du wie viel wir sollten das unter sich
aushandeln er gesät und irgendwie sagen
um die effizienz und die effektivität ob
das jetzt 100 sind erlaubt das 50 sind
das 300 zu viel sind wir glaube ich alle
einig weil wir uns das einfach also
diejenige etwas mehr drin sondern eher
von außen drauf schauen kannst du doch
mit mit klarem verstand kaum erklären
gründen wenn man das könnte und spürbare
und vor allem messbare ergebnisse
dadurch zu tage treten würden wer diese
diskussion ja hinfällig und lerne ich
habe keinen paten menschenverstand wenn
ich bin also ein bisschen
lena was denkst du bitte
koalitionsvertrag der am ende da
rauskommt welche note bitte haben was
man ja bislang nach den
sondierungsgesprächen gehört hat hat
mich das schon beeindruckt ich fand es
war eine kleine liberale handschrift
erkennbar was am ende rauskommt mir
macht ja schon ein bisschen angst dass
frau berger ja auch schon probiert druck
da ausüben das ist jetzt natürlich gar
nicht wenn die grünen druck auf sein
aber ich habe schon angst dass wenn
irgendwas wegfällt nochmal die
sondierungsphase mal gut aber jetzt also
bislang häufig auf die note 2
es kann auch noch zwei drei oder vier
berge wo sie köppel hat schon gesagt
also ohne dass das papier gelesen hat es
wird alles ganz heimlich oder nein ich
habe in dieser sendung einmal gesagt
dass das eigentlich sozial liberale oder
auch sozial liberal grüne regierungen in
deutschland zum teil besser performt
haben als man gedacht hat aber um
einfach etwas das aus der frivolen ecke
zu nehmen ich meine diese politik
invasion diese pandemie der politik in
unserem leben ist natürlich schon sehr
real wir beobachten im moment in einem
anderen bereichen massiv steigende
benzinpreise